give it up for dasha and anna from the
red scare podcast
[Applause]
cleveland what the [ __ ] is up
this this city my
favorite fact that i've just learned
about cleveland
is that a councilwoman uh has
issued a travel advisory not for syria
but for east cleveland there is a travel
advisory
currently for the eastern half
of this city because there are
so many police chases this is a fact
[Laughter]
covent is like number seven of what's
destroying
there is covet hid here 30 years ago
ah there are so many police chases it's
[ __ ] up the traffic
like people are getting an accident
because
cops are just ramming [ __ ]
pedestrians
on their way to apprehend a murderer
or something like that terrifying you've
never been to a place like this
never i'm a sweet west texas boy yeah
he's never been
to this place every i've been here five
years in a row
because comedy is good here yeah
comedy is very good here comedy is
always good
in places where people do not have hope
this is a fact in places whereas the
great chris hedges would say people
fetishize hope comedy my comedy is tough
but here i mean this restaurant and it's
lovely
is the nicest place in cleveland this is
it by far
this is it i mean rotisserie chicken
that's it that's the best you're gonna
do
in cleveland yeah you get a fried pickle
the food here is puzzling to me
the polish boy sandwich which is
a guy in the bat what do you mean come
on dick come on
it's a it was a kielbasa french fries
barbecue sauce and uh
coleslaw right is that what it is
i mean he doesn't even know whatever
woody allen did
is not as bad as that let's just say
that right now
i don't care what allegations come out
about woody allen
juan the tide is turning rogan texted me
today the tide is turning for woody
really that's what rogan said what's the
evidence he also said water cured cove
he's like it's like the movie signs
ma'am it's water yeah just one of us
those
same night shyamalan man let's throw
water on it ma'am
[Laughter]
hey i've done it eight times if he
doesn't have me back it is what it is
burn the bridges after you've crossed
them multiple times that's what i said
[Laughter]
but no it's uh woody i
did you see the first episode yeah put
the whole family in jail
everyone mia that's god she has a god
complex you don't adopt
17 children from war-torn countries if
you don't expect
some of them to get [ __ ]
she's importing taiwanese ladyboys
for her perv husband she's not even
adopting regular kids
she's adopting sex dolls from a un
human trafficking list
and i just keep looking at him if he's
gonna cut our mics but it's
so it's so crazy i want them all in jail
i want mia in jail
is she even asian she looks so weird i
don't know
what is her race it's troubling
what is me of pharaoh's race
i don't know i want to know she's irish
she's supposed to be irish
she looks like a banshee like an old
irish banshee
and she just adopted those [ __ ] kids
and and i think they should all just be
put away all of them in jail moses
that little [ __ ] harry potter yeah
the little
woody allen guy i hope moses is accused
of something soon
because moses is defending woody allen
hardcore
yeah moses is out right now going that's
my [ __ ] bro
nice don't [ __ ] he took me fishing yeah
he took me fishing he
gave me a buck i bought me a pair of
glasses he gives a [ __ ]
who he [ __ ] he married my sister
it doesn't matter because moses you got
to throw that in you got to be like yay
[ __ ] married my sister who cares
he's my dad ish kinda i don't know
didn't live with us barely saw him put
dylan in jail too for that [ __ ] hair
that red hair nothing justifies that
i don't care what happened i don't care
if
[ __ ] i don't care what happened you
cannot have blood red hair
and be taken seriously i don't feel any
sympathy for you
sitting there with blood red hair and
you know it's just rough here's the
thing with dylan and this is like me
i was hot as a kid legit
let me be very careful about how i
phrased my issue here with dylan farrow
do you see where i'm going here if i
was talking about molested now you'd go
i don't know
see what i mean but if i was a kid
that's why they keep
having to show dylan as a kid because
hbo is a little pedo
weird too they're like no but remember
she
did look like this like because dylan's
like he would just take me to the
[ __ ] attic and hbo is like okay let's
edit in
because it's not believable
at this juncture it is very i mean she
looks like she lives here you know like
it's not
i'm sorry but she does [ __ ]
if you saw dylan farrow [ __ ] serving
beer cheese pretzels
or whatever people eat here
half the city's a hospital that's the
other thing i love about cleveland
literally half the city's a clinic half
the entire city is a [ __ ] clinic
people just i walked into a restaurant
once people just getting ekgs i'm like
oh
i was like oh i thought this was the
ground round but apparently it's not
but dylan dylan has a problem that i
have we did not age into our sex appeal
we didn't that's okay
but when you're describing those events
you know it's a little like we're like
her because everybody's kind of doing
that everyone's like wait a minute
really i hope it all works out but hbo
[ __ ] up because they're releasing it
what is it once a week
it looks like once a week which it's who
the [ __ ] yeah here's the thing
with pedophile documentaries i know a
little bit about them
i know a little bit about pedophilia you
got to binge it
you got to get in and out
you got to get in and out of a good
pedophile doc you can't
be waiting because then you seem like a
creep
if you're waiting for the next
installment
like you seem like a freak if you're out
to launch you turn around you go
you know what i'm really uh waiting for
[Music]
i'm waiting for the next installment of
the woody allen to huh
i think this time he [ __ ] her i'm
waiting for that baby
give it to me you can't do that you can
have four watch parties you can't have
four
woody allen watch parties
get a hero come to the house this is the
episode where they go to the attic okay
i'm getting the cake a casada cake
the uh which is good it's a cleveland
cake it has um
very dry uh angel food cake that's old
and and a strawberry-ish
jelly and whipped cream so it's lovely
it's lovely oh it's it is
top of the lime but you know but i hope
hey man i hope i hope when he makes it
out okay i have no uh
you know it is what it is you know i
mean i hope he didn't do it
yeah mostly that
goes without saying i respect he didn't
do it
i respect mia and dylan so [ __ ] yeah
like if they're still
doing this [ __ ] to this [ __ ] guy
with hbo cameras on him and they're
still sitting there
and they're still going along man am i
[ __ ] like
wow all know it's [ __ ] if if dylan
and mia start a podcast together like
after this is all wrapped
and they just do a podcast about
socialism
after this
yeah what's what's the product launch
yeah that's true what's the merch line
the mia feral skin cream
yeah the mia faro
i mean she literally this is a fact
i don't know if this is a fact but i saw
it
she adopted a black daughter and then
she like she's like
put a photo out like happy birthday
shakshuka whatever the daughter's name
is
it's a brunch dish but it's something
similar sienna who cares you know serena
williams
and the point is i'm just saying i don't
know the name
and the point is supposedly she googled
in order to do that mia farah black
daughter to get a photo of the daughter
really yeah that's what it that's what i
read the online
that she put me up for a black daughter
just to find
she has like 30 she has too many kids
from too many places to keep track
of all of her children you know but
we're bombing syria
so it's gonna be good we're bombings
thank god were you getting a little
tired of us
not bombing syria i woke up
every day feeling like [ __ ] because
bombs were not
dropping on hospitals in syria
i was so upset
i said when can we do a fake war with
syria
and we're just bombing the [ __ ] out of
syria no one really knows why
i think it's because the bitcoin story
is over
i think that's literally what happened
like amc stock tanked
i lost 18 hund the next time i see dave
portnoy i'm gonna lunge at him when he's
reviewing a pizza and bite his [ __ ]
neck
[Music]
[Laughter]
he won't have me on that podcast with
that tick tocker i've tried to get on
like multiple times
no he won't have me on bffs no with him
and the
child that they discuss have you watched
that
he does his thing and he says whatever
he says and then the kid goes like this
the kid's like
yeah the response
to everything dave says dave's like
business is like this the kid's like
yeah that's fire
i had dinner with that kid we all went
out to dinner and that kid came to
dinner
and i was sitting there and literally
we're all deciding on the appetizers and
you know
he's like sitting there and he's like
and i go i go what do you want to eat
and he goes the calamari is
fire i was like okay
this is like this is where it's at you
know but we're we're bombing syria
and uh to send a message to send a
message that's it
to yemen yeah uh that
we will continue to let saudi arabia
carpet bomb you
we don't know why we don't know why
we're in war we have no idea why
they used to make up reasons to go in
remember that
isis isil yeah remember that there were
different ones
well this is the lava this is i see
there's nothing now
they don't even make up a fake there
were fake things that they tried hard
they'd be like
five guys dressed like ninjas sawn a
guy's head off
and they'd be like this is why we got to
go in here and i'm like there's more
[ __ ] going on in east cleveland
than that go to east cleveland there is
much more
[ __ ] going on in east cleveland than
there is in [ __ ] damascus but okay
they used to make [ __ ] up now they now
you just find out about it on twitter
and you go all right this bomb in syria
it's that hyper normalization did you
see the new adam curtis doc
okay well just eliminate that
it's good but i'm just sick of his [ __ ]
too yeah did you see hyper normalization
he does he's good docs he's like a bbc
documentarian
but his whole thing is like he is the
why the world looks the way it does
and it's like dude we get it like we
know
already how it looks you know it's like
do you ever wonder why
how we got here yeah like no how do we
get out of here
how did we get to this place where no
one believes anything
and they never will what are we doing
you know
do you know why we're in a place where
no one can do anything to change
anything and we're all sitting around
staring at each other
no one trusts anyone and everything is
bad
yes do we have a follow-up
he just keeps doing that he keeps
coasting on that you know
hey man i just hope the weinstein
brothers have forgiven me
i just hope they're bred so on clubhouse
what's happening now i will mention them
every
podcast until uh we we get in a
full-scale war and they are not ready ah
no idea what i will do no idea i'm
kidding i like there
i agree with them that's the thing i
hate getting in wars
with people i agree with but we'll do it
ah
but on clubhouse which is this app where
you it's an audio only invite
app where you people talk to each other
in these dumb little rooms
and and you have to get invited into
them or whatever woke people like
virulently woke people have come into
these
rooms and what they're doing and this is
sad
but a little funny uh is they are called
they're like
you have to be asked to be a speaker so
what they're doing is they're calling
like
the weinsteins on stage on clubhouse
inviting them up and then they're saying
like [ __ ] you you're a geogenesis
and then asking him for money they're
like hit my venmo
you white piece of [ __ ] literally that's
what people are doing on clubhouse now
they're like dude just just hit my venmo
white people you're not allowed to speak
just [ __ ] hit my venmo
and like some of them are doing it i
guess these [ __ ] cucks i don't know
some of these [ __ ] are like all right
i'll give you 19
i'm sorry it's so weird
it's such a weird app because it's all
it's like there's woke people
there'll be a room where they'll be like
is cobra kai too
white yeah
and then there'll be a room about like
bitcoin and then there'll be
rooms that i do which are like i do the
serious rooms the ones that matter
i'll do the rooms like how to become a
cancer influencer you know
how to build a brand while in uh a
prison for statutory rape
i do the ones that matter the ones that
you know
the alt-right's on there now by the way
is he all right on there yeah the sang
cry cpac let him right in thank god i
was getting bored
q anon's on there too yeah me and ray
did a room the other day how to be both
woke and q
anon we did a room where we go the the
stunning lack of diversity at the
capitol riot
[Laughter]
just a sea of whites ah not good
i would like to see more i mean ray had
a great point
the great great comp said hey if you can
build
remember when they built the gallows for
pence they built the gallows outside of
capitol
if you have time to build the gallows
you can put in a wheelchair ramp
and you can allow the disabled and
differently abled
and and neuro what's it called with
their with the autistic whichever one is
now what do they call it
asperger's no no they call it is it
differently abled or
neuro intellectually and developmentally
disabled no neuro neuro-divergent
neurodivergent yeah we need
autistic indigenous
cripples yes to feel welcome
in the q movement and
i want to invite them to also try to
kill
nancy pelosi with a letter opener
that's i remember the quarantine started
everyone was like the dolphins are back
in the canals and it ended with a guy in
viking horns
trying to kill aoc with a pen i was like
this is a real interesting turn
this [ __ ] [ __ ] is taken huh
remember that dumb [ __ ] thing that
poem in the beginning the guy's like
we are going to listen to each other he
was talking to his kid yeah
it's like a children's book we're going
to learn how to listen we're going to
learn yeah how did that work out
yeah but i mean that's my hope my hope
is that we're able to uh but i don't
know what's going to happen with that
app either i mean that app could bomb
when everyone gets vaccinated by the way
they're vaccinating everyone way too
quickly
i'm getting very nervous because i don't
want to see anyone
for a few years
i'm getting a little nervous that
thanksgiving might happen
are you watching thanksgiving like a
hawk
they're like we've actually 100 people
i'm like why don't you slow the [ __ ]
down how about you not vaccinate a few
people i don't need to see my [ __ ]
aunt i
yeah she is she is not happy with me
i don't know that i'll ever be able to
go to another family event
now that i have destroyed that
relationship but everyone in my family
secretly was texting me like dude
you got her so good that's how you know
you're from an irish family everyone's
like it's so
good i thought they were calling to
disown me they're like you
nailed that [ __ ]
i'm like she started sheath underwear
oh yeah we got to do these live
uh sheath underwear it is good
it is good a lot of the things we
advertise we don't even know what they
are
before we read the ads we really have no
idea
i remember when we were advertising
monday.com and they got mad i'm like i
don't know what he did i read the whole
and i go i don't know what it is
still i didn't know what it was
monday.com i'm like i don't know what is
it
they're like it's a peer-to-peer
software i'm like what
what is this but she's underwear is
underwear it's actually
underwear it's good it's uh it's support
you have the pouch for your penis
and balls and if you're a woman with a
penis and balls
or a man with a penis in balls or you
don't identify in the gender binary and
you have a penis and balls or you've
added
a nice tiny little penis and balls it
was sculpted out of
a vagina like some flabby loose vag skin
that they made
into a little vienna sausage corkscreen
but you're like [ __ ] yeah
i feel better like this or if you've
taken a penis and then
i often think of doing this and just
splitting it right down the middle
and throwing up the turkey on either
side of the leg
and and having a vag but i still keep my
sack
any configuration of 2021 genitalia
sheath underwear
is great whether it's a [ __ ] or just a
flab of [ __ ] beef you want to stick
in there
you can do whatever you need you could
swim in them we we use them as swimsuits
you know they're great
doesn't matter it's good you should uh
the guy's a big comedy fan which is why
i can do this
if you go to sheathunderware.com is this
the guy who's in the military
uh yes yes yes yes yes
this guy started an underwear company uh
after he got back from iraq
so support him uh sheath underwear dot
com
use code tim to save 20 off if you use
code tim
you save 20 off the underwear uh
then this is better help
i mean if you've listened to the show if
you have any familiarity with this show
the idea that this company
i mean truly amazing
that they would do this ad
we promised to be good for this run of
the and i'm being good you're being good
i'm saying i'm shocked yeah
and pleasantly surprised we have a long
history
we have a long history with them and
that's nice but it's good because what
it is
is it's counseling do you get that
it's counseling when you sad or when
you're mad
dan has problem you went to a therapist
right dan has prop because
dan graduated college and went wait a
minute why why do i have to leave it you
know
many shitty people in his generation are
like why do the beer pong tournaments
have to end
but they do so he got sad about that
he was sad and he had to go to a
therapist and go i don't understand
what's going on he had to leave florida
i didn't leave the beach
put on shoes and be a human being and it
was sad
and challenging and new but
during the pandemic it's hard i'm not
who cares no i just don't i get it
ah dinner in the comments i can't see i
mean i love they send the copy like i
don't know what i'm doing
it's when you're sad or mad or
anxious or you're in a loveless marriage
you can call
betterhelp.com atlp betterhelp.com
what's the promo code
so this i have to read directly this
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp and
tim dillon show listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
tim d
yay all right round one of ads done
better help everybody's talking about
bitcoin every unemployed loser that i
know
is talking about bitcoin the excitement
someone has in bitcoin
is directly proportional to literally
having nothing else going on in their
life
anyone with anything happening does not
need to bring up bitcoin every three
minutes
are you invested on the market i am not
why
because i have no money to invest in the
markets but you are
i am yeah i'm long on a couple things
ben thinks he's warren buffett because
he has 750 dollars
after he [ __ ] his wife she goes to bed
and he goes down to his basement and
goes on reddit and just stares at the
dogecoin dog
for three hours and yet he's been on
reddit every day for like the last two
years but somehow wasn't on it enough to
make me any [ __ ] money
when we could have went into gme [ __ ]
early i got on that [ __ ] train late
and got thrown the [ __ ] off it
you could have came it was just a meme i
didn't think it was really gonna be a
revolution
i didn't really think it was gonna take
off well we could have made some [ __ ]
money dude if you had [ __ ]
caught a [ __ ] glimpse of what was
happening
you know what i mean we could have
hooked up dylan farrow with some [ __ ]
investment advice
yeah what if dylan farrow made 19
million dollars on gamestop
what if she
[Laughter]
yeah she's like it's very odd doing this
documentary because i just didn't make
20 million dollars
on a very uh crazy play a short squeeze
on gamestop
i would love if the next uh part of the
documentary was just mia pharaoh talking
about bitcoin for the entire hour
what he never considered other
currencies he just wanted to [ __ ] dylan
[Laughter]
i mean it's it's it's bad out there i
don't know how i feel about therapy it's
good you were in it for a while right
yeah i had to stop though my therapist
was too old and kind of like out of it
like she was like i'd be like telling a
story and she'd be like what's uber i'm
like you're missing the point
it has nothing to do with what i'm
trying to tell you
how old was she i don't know like an
indistinguishable old
you know what i mean like she was up
there like really up there probably
close to 80 pushing 80. 74 how did you
get her she was free
i mean that was that was kind of it what
did she do
you sure was a therapist not like an old
lady in a church i wasn't
sold i wasn't so it might have been his
own old woman on a park bench you were
talking to
like you're like forrest gump yeah
i told her one time i was like yeah i'm
thinking about doing mushrooms she's
like that sounds nice i'm like well
maybe this isn't super helpful
like i don't know she's like i love
mushrooms peppers onions you put them in
a pan
you saute them and if you do it right
your husband doesn't punch you in the
face
[Applause]
i mean i love you you have an elderly
therapist yeah she's nice though
she's nice had it like i had one i had
one uh i had one
therapist this is literally the fact
that one therapist was an irish guy
um the worst kind of thing is this the
worst therapist because they're all so
funny
and uh i believe i was like i don't know
what i was like 14 years old or
something
and he's like at the end of the session
like all he
seemed to surmise he was like all right
so you're a homosexual
and you love george w bush
i was like yeah i think he has the right
strategies for
the time we're in i think we have to
honor our commitment to the people of
iraq
and i'd like to suck dick and i don't
know
what why those things are all
but at the end of the that was like at
the end of the
thing that was like his diagnosis he was
like you're like bush
but you don't like bush you know i'm
like right
he's like all right well that's 97 i'm
like
all right well i don't really think
there's
i don't think there's a need for the
people go to therapy in florida where
you're from or does everyone just go to
the like
they don't they don't even know they
wouldn't even consider that as an option
right yeah
because why go to therapy when you could
go to a bar called the land shark
exactly
that is the therapy yeah florida man you
love florida so much i do
i love it it's the greatest state of the
union
it's but it's objectively not it's
probably not now but it is fun
it is fun yeah but life's not about fun
no it's not
thank you that's what me and dan do on
the road
we're in a car and he says something
like that and i go but the world doesn't
work
like that and then he goes yeah yeah i
guess not okay and then we just keep
driving
he's a happy kid i need a happy kid i
can't have another me here
you know you know i'm like tower seven
then the other one goes what are that
tower one and two we can't have that
we can't have that you know you know
i go tower seven he goes is that a good
movie so that's
why it works he's a happy guy
ben is a demon i mean ben is his dark
uh what did what did do you remember
exact quote from the car about in east
cleveland last night
oh i said i was trying to learn about
east cleveland
on the plane and he's the darkest human
being and from what i can tell it's just
like people go to east cleveland to like
murder crack heads after they rape them
that was the first thing he said in the
car five minutes in
he goes and he has the delivery like
this hey guys with the vape he's like
people in east cleveland are just
murdering the crackheads they framed
i'm like oh what a fun and then we just
listen to chris hedges speeches driving
around east cleveland
i don't know if you know chris hedges
but he's great and he's just
[Laughter]
but he's just he gets it like kind of
what's going on
and he's like we're just driving around
east cleveland and literally we're
watching chris hedges on youtube and
he's like the issue before us
is death the death of societies the
collective death
of the globalized world the death of
industrial
i was just driving around when was and i
want to put this forth to the audience
did we have a mic that we could pass
around
hey do we have a wireless sound i want
to know when cleveland was a [ __ ]
because i know the rockefellers lived
here
and i know you guys have the rock and
roll hall of fame and i know that like
[ __ ] was going on at once you guys had
millionaires row
millionaires row yeah look at those
girls in the back yes
millionaires
they are not that's the real housewives
of cleveland back there
they winter in cleveland and they summer
in cleveland
the real housewives of cleveland some of
them have refrigerators
can you imagine that sad housewives
franchise
my name is dawn i live in cleveland ohio
i always knew i was one of the upper
crusts because we had two cars
and they work
my husband works in a tile factory it
burnt down now he's in the house
all the time which is strange but i'm
still taking a girls trip
you know the real housewives of
cleveland
see how the other half lives the
the hottest woman on the real housewives
of cleveland would just be
a diabetic who could afford insulin
literally just staying alive would be
like the [ __ ] like
you know how they have those shitty like
in the beginning of the show they're
like
you know they'll be like i don't care
what anyone says about me i'm
real like those dumb little intros it
would be a woman who's like
i have type 1 diabetes but don't worry
boys i can afford my needle
the real housewives of cleveland
there's also a lot of people here that
like naturally transgender they don't
have to have the surgery which is nice
there's a lot of naturally gender
non-specific kind of orbs of flesh
wandering around
it's true they're so beaten down the
gender
down what's a gender at that point you
know who cares
just a leathery-faced old catrice mitt
crawling down the street
looking for a pool of beer to dunk their
head in what's the [ __ ] gender at
that point
you just opened two legs and all you see
is mashed potatoes anyway
if you sell stuff online you're
definitely
you're definitely in the right business
more people are shopping online than
ever
that means a lot of orders coming in and
a lot of orders you'll need to ship
out fast that's why online sellers like
you need
ship station amazon fc or even your own
website ship station funnels all the
orders into one simple interface
you can manage from anywhere even your
cell phone with ship station small
business
can now access the same rates reserved
for fortune 500 it's a great product
uh use my code tim dillon to get a
60-day freight trial free trial that's
two months free no hassle
stress free shipping 60-day free trial
stress free shipping promo code tim
dillon you can sell your undergarments
you can sell things you stole you can
sell
garbage art that your kids make you
could just say they're dying
what a great idea say your children are
dying
and sell their art my mother said to me
once i'll never respect her more than
the moment she said this
i was like in fifth grade i go mom i
don't have the report done she goes
just tell the teacher i died
i'm like yeah but grandma like works at
the school my mom's like right
i guess don't do that shipstation.com
promo code tim dillon make ship happen
and then
last one here the last one they're gonna
reject a lot of these and we're gonna
have to cut them up when you if you hear
them on the show they'll be literally
yeah
in seconds they'll take out everything
it'll just be like ship station
good literally they will not
we have to send the ads in for approval
now yeah
yeah that's most of what my job is now
is
fighting with them to leave jokes in and
editing
what is their problem they why did the
spoon turn
[Music]
spoon was with us for a while and then i
went tell them
tell everyone exactly what spoon so
magic spoon told me they said
uh that we can't do any content about uh
children getting abused or
uh uh killed or killed that was their
words
in the act we can't talk about children
being killed or murdered
in the ad for cereal or sexually
assaulted well then i can't do it i
i i try i edit i mean i'll try
i'll try to get through it but i mean no
promises the whole point
of magic spoon is that the kids that
grew up with those cereals growing up
were the types of kids whose parents
went to a bar all night
then came home walked him out of a dead
seat just started pounding on him for no
reason
and then passed out the reward for those
kids was a [ __ ] nice
lucky charms breakfast they didn't get
college out of it they got a nice
breakfast and every now and then i get
to go over their house they'd have a
black eye
true story and a bloody lip and we'd
have a great [ __ ]
cereal breakfast and that's what i was
trying to capture
and then some blue hair [ __ ] tech
[ __ ] they
they got really mad about the the part i
had to edit out was
about the kid getting tied to the
radiator and getting his head beaten in
and then them running him over with the
car over and over
that was brilliant i felt hungry
hearing that i wanted a nice
crunchy keto cereal when hearing
about that kid being beaten and then ran
over with a car
they didn't like that and what do you
who do you talk to over there people
have to call you
yeah they they they contact me through
our ad guy and then i have to barter
with him and then why not why don't they
contact me
i can include you on the call oh no bad
idea
bad idea i'll give them a [ __ ] piece
of my mind
i'm not allowed to speak to anyone this
is after the whole airbnb fiasco
i am to be kept silent in a room
with cigarettes and i'm to be let out an
hour a week
and then back into the cage i cannot
speak to the world uh you know but they
never sued us those ladies
oh mila and uh yeah no no do with the
names now so
not test that sorry but they never sued
us
no never never but uh they were happy
about rogan's comment they were like joe
rogan is welcome any time at the time
you know is that what they said
yeah that's what they said on their
instagram stories what they said
yeah oh good uh joe rogan doesn't need
to go to your house you dirty dyke
because he has real [ __ ] money you
stupid piece of [ __ ]
nobody needs to stay in your litter box
of a [ __ ] house you [ __ ]
wait honeys wait and watch we're just
getting started
okay we're just getting [ __ ] started
you [ __ ] clam divers
they [ __ ] went at me on the gram like
that and you didn't [ __ ] tell me
stories i thought you saw it
i didn't [ __ ] i'm blocked
no every screenshot ever since i
threatened to kill them i'm blocked
i threatened to kill them they blocked
me like children
so wait a minute what what did they do
they shared that thing
uh that rogan said when you did the
podcast last about how rogan said it was
a beautiful place and he'd love to stay
at a place like he's on
dmt and they said joe rogan is welcome
any time at our airbnb
thank you so much joe
whatever i don't like this alliance
between joe rogan and these two dykes
i don't like it i can see it shaping up
and i don't like it
do you think i did anything wrong no
[Laughter]
dan dan sees a lot of my behavior and
much of it you probably disagree with
uh i mean who can agree with everything
that someone does
you know but you're a young person what
you need to understand
is when you're an older person you
realize the value of going to war with
every person that you saved
we got in trouble for cutting the line
at a whataburger we did that was
[ __ ] though
we didn't even we didn't even know the
line worked we didn't even know the line
was functioning
yeah and it's supposed to be texas tough
guy i'm texas i'm a tough guy i'm going
to shoot you
and then you go on a facebook group like
a con and whine about it
yeah neighbors uncensored yeah neighbors
uncensored
25. you know what that group's about
hard r
you know what that neighbor's uncensored
in texas is about
letting it fly neighbors uncensored how
much coded racial language is in that
group
i just want to post on neighbors
uncensored about the new neighbors they
seem a little
different does anyone share my concerns
about the new neighbors they have a
lot of children i don't know athletic
sure but i'm a little nervous
i'm a little nervous about them darting
out into the middle of the street to get
a basketball
if you hear what i'm saying it's
neighbors uncensored in texas
expressvpn if you you know what's not
fair
the fact that netflix hides thousands of
shows and movies
from you based on your location and they
have the ner
and then they have the nerve to increase
the price that's right
they've just raised their prices once
again now you could just cancel your
subscription to protest
or you could be smart about it and make
sure you're getting your full money's
worth by using expressvpn
like i do you might not know what's on
netflix
in your country is completely different
from someone in the uk or japan has on
theirs
expressvpn i can control which country i
want netflix to think i'm in
this is such an interesting ad because
the hope
the real hope with this service
is that you are watching japanese
netflix
i pray i'm not saying it
i'm saying i pray to god
that you are using this service yes to
watch
japanese netflix
[Laughter]
here's the best part it's not just for
netflix
you can use expressvpn to unlock shows
on other streaming
services too
it's super fast works on your
phone
laptop smart tvs
so you can watch your shows on the big
screen
with zero buffering what
ring of hell is reserved for me after
reading this ad
call to action so be smart
stop paying for i gotta cut that out i
gotta cut that out
it's a joke you can't make it out edit
it out sorry
it's all right it's our last week on
youtube like every week
i hope he gets us that [ __ ] wait to get
your broken spotify buddy
so it lands every time every episode we
go this will be it
so hopefully patreon is still
holding out for now yeah all of their
shows are what patreon's wild
they've got chapel and kumtown and us
and like anime
people just want to [ __ ] cartoons yeah
anime asmr is big on there
what the [ __ ] is that anime like a
cartoon yeah it's anime but the anime
characters are doing asmr so people can
you know you like asmr daniel no why not
i don't know i mean i don't have nothing
against it i just do you ever feel like
weird when someone goes
[Laughter]
i told you this the other day what if it
was a really hot girl with my exact
voice
like hottest girls you've seen big tits
everything perfect but it's just my
exact voice
practice i turn off the lights she's
like it's dark yeah
it's real doctor this country is wrong
let's practice right now you're on a
date can you do it all right all right
so
hey it's nice to meet you yeah
you're from florida yeah i am where are
you from new york
yeah but i'm hot like i'm really hot
huge dance
i'm just fingering my perfectly bald
pink [ __ ]
but i'm going ah
so just get expressvpn it helps the show
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
tim dillon that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p on
vpn.com tim dillon to learn more
see what happened to those hands we'll
we'll shave them down
maybe we'll just put them out but i will
bleep out the that part
well don't we have to get we have to get
approval so we have
we're not in a contract to get approval
but we our word is our bond
right what a
horrible bond
what a horrible bond um should we do the
wireless mic by the way with the having
a wireless mic is anyone working here
okay thank you i feel like we've just
gotten into like an abandoned homeless
give the wireless mic to someone i don't
even care who it is just give it to
someone
someone that looks uh i
spoke to melanie the other day yeah
really uh what was the follow-up you
were supposed to call her a year ago but
it was 1 45 in the morning and
where are the dirt bags yes see the
thing about having a fan base
is sometimes it's very scary
[Applause]
sometimes it's very very scary um
i i do speak to melanie melanie's gonna
hopefully come out to visit us
and podcast with us in march
are you melanie
was that your que the only question that
was it
okay well we're gonna get now we love
melanie
dude cleveland is [ __ ] wild
remember three years ago somebody named
melanie we're gonna call her what
happened with that
i don't know we're still gonna do that
we haven't found the time was that it
yeah
that's my that's my question it's been
keeping me up nice for the last year and
a half you know i was laying on a
ventilator going what am i melanie
okay give it to someone else if you can
i apologize
uh when you guys come to the city what
do you actually do because i live here
and
this is the first time i've left my
house in four months
yeah well by the way that's correct
you're doing the right thing what do we
do what did we do we went to the
fig place what's the what was it called
the flying fig
we went to the flying fig all right
bring it in
uh it was fine sweet people loved it
loved
them we went to uh town hall yeah we
went videos today
i mean i don't know i don't want to
break some bad news to you there's not a
ton
of extracurricular activities here that
don't involve cooking a bunch of crystal
and smoking it in an alley
i don't exactly i don't want to walk
through the rock and roll hall of fame
oh the ramones like who gives a [ __ ]
like
i wish it was nicer weather and i'd go
walk around by the nestle quick colored
river or something and
think about throwing myself in which is
usually i'm usually here in the summer
and i just walk by the river and imagine
how many dead hookers
oh i wanted to talk about my friend bud
munster he died my friend bud monster
died and bud is a character from the
show
he uh he's my friend joe's father
he um i've gotten two boating accidents
with him
uh we used to drink together and do
cocaine and take uh
pills and he died which is very sad
because he'd never stop doing that which
is
not advisable but he was the coolest guy
and one of my favorite people in the
world and he said some of the funniest
things that i've ever heard in my life
uh you know once his wife said to him
bud you should get he was like the fun
guy the party guy
we'd all go over to their house high
school parties and [ __ ] like that
um he'd take people out on his boat for
48 hours straight just drunk and throw
them in the water and watch them drown
and stuff
he was a good guy he loved freedom you
know people don't value freedom anymore
and you know these tick tocks come
and everyone else but bud uh you know
his wife said to him once his wife goes
why don't you get a [ __ ] job and he
looked at he goes what am i gonna work
like some loser those are
memories that i really um i cherish he
was a good a great man and it was very
sad
he kind of i don't know if it was od i
think it was kind of a suicide yeah
and his kids were my friends are so dark
they are the darkest why i tell dan
story i mean this poor little kid's head
but i mean my friends are the darkest
he texted his family um uh
my life of service is over let me get
the exact text
it's on my phone i wish i had it first
of all you didn't serve anyone so that's
kind of hilarious
like my life of service is over like he
never
did any for like anyone but he was fun
with me like we had fun
and that's important too so many people
forget that it's important to have fun
even with people that are doing horrible
things and he
said um he said like my life of service
is over
and he said uh my earthly ron whatever
he said he goes
he's over and his son had no idea he was
serious because he used to threaten us
all the time
so his son literally said this was the
last words he said his father his son
literally texted him
okay take care
and then he did it but that's so [ __ ]
bad
that's so bad to just end it like that
[ __ ] bun just where he goes they're
all gonna feel like a piece of [ __ ] now
i know that's what bud felt like right
at the end he goes you know what
they're all gonna feel like [ __ ] okay
take care oh i will take care
oh i will take care and you're going to
be feeling pretty stupid but we're all
laughing
about it you know they're they want me
to do the eulogy and i do want to we
might have to cancel the show i might
have to fly down there and do the eulogy
because i've had so many fun times with
the guy he introduced me to lisa's
lounge
uh to to a place called the helm i spent
a decade of my life
in a crippling drug addiction and
financial ruin
and a lot of that was with him and
without that
there's no podcast truly to be honest
with you there's no podcast i would have
went to some
[ __ ] liberal arts school truly i
would have been like
i believe in the future and hope and
i have a taint and whatever i would
major in like
i just be like [ __ ] i'd be a fat
activist just like
on the cover of a magazine with my
[ __ ] [ __ ] out
and i'd be living in vermont and [ __ ]
i'd be a full dyke i would have
transitioned to allez
i would have split my [ __ ] irish dick
out and just made it into a fat
[ __ ] fat french dip
and i narrowly
avoided that okay fate could have came
out of the closet easier like when i was
younger and been happy
and like been financially stable and had
a good life
and man we would all not be here so one
of the reasons i didn't do that was
because blood monster showed me
sometimes it is more important
to go out and get drunk than to heal the
wounds of your childhood
you know what i mean sometimes in
cleveland you get this
sometimes that line of coke is more
important than seeing a shrink
sometimes that oxycontin is just what
you need you don't need to call an old
friend
do you understand sometimes being drunk
on a boat is just the best thing you can
do
at the time bud monster was
uh a guy that went with me every day to
a murder trial
that changed my life because after the
murder trial i said i'm gonna sober up
i'm gonna come out of the closet and
then i'm gonna do stand-up comedy
but i was 25 years old i was the same
age as you literally you know
and uh bud came to the murder trial
every day with me because he was
unemployed
and he didn't have anything to do and he
loved murder trials
because they're really fun and they're
interesting and if you ever get a chance
to be a juror on a murder trial do it
not
one of these dumb things where like
somebody slips and falls into wendy's
and they're like i want 80 grand who
cares
but i mean i'm talking this was murder
torture rape the guy
uh stabbed her in each eye stabbed her
so many times
that the coroner didn't know uh how many
they had to stop at 65. he goes to flesh
is so bruised that at 65 times
we had to stop so what i'm trying to say
is this was
well worth it you know like this was a
good
i mean you know it's it's it was a rough
experience for everyone her more so
i did a lot of sitting and judging which
is nice in a jury box you sit and judge
and i would crinkle chips you know as
the coroner was saying this i'd be like
i'd be like and there was a laceration
on each eye
and bud would be sitting in the back
they thought bud was a member of the
family they let blood in the sentencing
they let bud go into sentencing because
they thought bud every day bud would
come
to and then after uh we'd go to lunch
every day and then after the trial we'd
drive home
and get drunk and then tell everyone at
the local bar everything that was going
on with the truck
we would like update them we'd be like
oh they [ __ ] brought this expert in
and
whatever and [ __ ] you know and the guy
was really guilty i don't i'm i'm not
super sure about that but he was like he
looked weird
and he's in jail life plus 50 but
whatevs and
bud was a real big part of my life
because he was there
and uh we'd go to the trial every day
and uh then he went to sentencing we
went back for
and me and bud went back for the
sentencing the jury came back it was
like a big deal on long island you could
look it up
you know don't overturn it or but uh and
then
bud went to the sentencing and then we
went out afterwards a few days later
we're on his boat and we crashed into
the piling of a bridge
and we fell off the boat and then we're
like both bleeding and he looked at me
because you can't hang out with me
anymore and i said why
and he goes i'm trying to kill myself
like he said it very seriously
he's like i'm trying to kill myself and
then it hit me i'm like oh
he's trying to kill himself you know
what i mean
like this is not fun for him he's in the
depths of an addiction
but it was also a little fun but it was
like
you know and then i forgot what i said i
probably said okay take care but at the
end of it
i don't know what i said but and then
the last time i saw him was with you
yeah and and you had met him briefly i
did
yeah and what were your impression
it's not the most surprising thing yeah
you know like he didn't seem
super healthy you know yeah you ever
seen the movie adaptation
yes what was that actor chris cooper
michael cooper yeah that guy
chris cooper this is a dan carney basic
[ __ ] simulation this is what he does
it's the academy award-winning film i
know i know
this is what daniel kind of looks like
have you ever seen
[ __ ] american pie
[Applause]
you know stifler's mom yeah well
but no i know what do you kind of look
like him but like with
less ambition bud had lived a life a
wildlife
he had like sold blow with like george
young back in the day
he he was hanging out in fort lauderdale
when it was like called fort
luderdale because there were so many
quaaludes there he spent a lot of time
in florida
uh you know it really didn't work like
rarely worked
barely worked didn't really work didn't
have jobs which i always liked
i like people that don't work i think
they're fun
have you ever gone to someone's house a
tuesday at 11am and they're there
there's something nice about that
right isn't there something nice when
someone's there at 11am they'll just
like yeah if you want to do something
i'm like yeah
[ __ ] let's do it you know i don't
want to deal with people that are like
well i got three meetings i got a four
o'clock i like it at 7 30. no
he was always home uh
he was a a special character you know
and it's sad that he um
is no longer with us but i guess in one
way it's good because i don't know what
the next
i don't know what like the back nine was
gonna be
like there was no shot that it was gonna
turn around
and be good you know he built a house in
georgia
that's like crazy it looks crazy it's
like
it's it's like literally like built like
like a like
just like someone on drugs
built a house like that's literally what
it looks like like things are uneven and
walls don't make sense like it's
literally
like a [ __ ] maze so
but it is i mean it's sad everyone's
dying
except my family how
how in god's name has my
family escaped
what has come for everyone you know
cleveland it's a it's an honor to to be
here
you know this is a real world-class
city
you may say hey a large percentage of
our population dresses in
reynold's wrap who cares
who cares many of our restaurants serve
fish which is actually just chicken or
fried bread doesn't matter
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter it's
gonna turn around
i said i believe i believe your time is
coming
you know what like i truly truly believe
that cleveland like its best days are
ahead of them
but but i also believe that about bud
munster
thank you guys so much you're a lot of
fun thank you guys for coming out
we got a stand-up show you guys rock ben
avery dan carney follow these guys
thank you so much we really appreciate
it have a good night